[Musique]
bienvenue à tous bienvenue à tous ravis
de vous retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro
de paris saclay tv ces dernières
semaines ont été intenses que
d'inauguration sur votre territoire
à commencer par cet oeil de l'aviation
civile si tu es un juste derrière moi il
cote ciel et guide les avions de la
région parisienne
un radar ultra performant qui s'intègre
dans l'environnement l'environnement
justement une priorité pour le pea paris
saclay qui a décidé d'installer un
rocher sur votre territoire
cochet qui va accueillir des abeilles
une espèce que nous devons protéger et
qui faisait fort utile les goélands pas
aussi il ya des nouveautés avec la mise
en place du programme qualifiant
territoriales une opportunité pour
quinze stagiaires de se former aux
métiers de la voirie à la fois sur le
terrain et en entreprise enfin nous
irons à l'edf lab un lieu devenu
incontournable et qui accueillait pour
la première fois une exposition
itinérante l'observeur du design
notre agenda ce sera à la fin de cette
émission tous les rendez vous à ne pas
rater dans la semaine
attention l'oeil de l'aviation civile
nous regardent enfin ce radar ultra
performant scrutent le ciel
il guide observe les avions de la région
parisienne ils jouent un rôle essentiel
dans la sécurité aérienne
comme nous le rappelle le maurice
georges le directeur des services de la
navigation aérienne
[Musique]
je suis très très fier et très heureux
d'inaugurer aujourd'hui ce nouveau radar
de paris saclay ce radar est un élément
essentiel de la sécurité aérienne
puisqu'il nous permet de communiquer
avec
l'ensemble des avions à plus de 250 km
donc soit pour les aéroports parisiens
mais aussi les autoroutes du ciel au
dessus de paris
c'est un élément essentiel de notre
réseau de sécurité aérienne françaises
outre le symbole je pense de modernité
pour l'établissement par rapport à
l'ancien radar de palaiseau ce radar est
beaucoup plus haut et c'est l'oeil de
l'aviation civile donc le fait d'avoir
une élévation suffisante permet
d'accompagner le développement de
paris-saclay sans que sa vision soit
masqué et donc d'où son altitude assez
élevé sa performance
après c'est l'oeil et c'est un système
qui s'intègrent particulièrement bien
dans son environnement
du point de vue architectural je crois
que il n'ya qu'à voir la qualité
architecturale qu'on se rencontre mais
du point de vue aussi de l'environnement
électromagnétique
j'insiste sur cet aspect oeil c'est une
technologie de l'aviation civile qui
s'appelle le radar secondaire c'est à
dire que ce radar travail en
interrogation réponses avec les avions
et avec des puissances d'émission très
faible ce qui est une grande différence
notamment avec les radars militaires de
détection qui eux doivent pouvoir
détecter n'importe quel accrue et donc
en voie d émissions radars beaucoup plus
forte
ça ce sont des émissions très faible de
communication avec les avions ce qui
permet d'insérer ce radar dans un
environnement urbain sans absolument
aucun problème de sécurité
que nous étions à la fois dans notre
modernisation mais aussi en
accompagnement pour pouvoir intégrer ce
radar dans l'environnement et
l'établissement public a travaillé pour
nous comme maître d'ouvragé délégué les
crédits sont du ministre des transports
mais l'établissement public a
effectivement fait une maîtrise ouvrage
remarquable et ce qui n'a perdu de tenir
des délais et de mettre en service ce
radar depuis le mois de juillet
sans aucun problème de mise en service
tant c'est vraiment une réussite de
coopération entre l'aviation civile et
l'établissement 5 bet
un radar très puissant certes mais
est-ce qu'il détecte les abeilles qui
butinent aux alentours les abeilles une
espèce qu'il faut protéger le pea paris
saclay a décidé de mettre en place ce
rucher avec l'unaf l'union nationale de
l'apiculture française y est même du
miel du campus paris saclay alors
pourquoi est ce que c'est important
d'accueillir ces abeilles ici sur votre
territoire
tout de suite les précisions de marlyse
boucourt de lunas
[Musique]
nous sommes à l'inauguration du rucher
de le paix à paris saclay le che qui est
derrière nous dans le cadre du programme
abeille sentinelle de l'environnement
l'unaf donc l'union nationale de
l'apiculture française c'est un syndicat
qui comprend vingt mille salariés et
environ 500000 ruche un des principaux
syndicats français unaf a développé en
2005 le programme abeille sentinelle de
l'environnement suite tous les profs de
mortalité des abeilles est dans le but
de sensibiliser le public de leur
apprendre également le fonctionnement
d'une ruche la vie de la ruche la vie de
l'abeille est de faire en sorte de
sensibiliser la population et on peut
dire que l'objectif aujourd'hui est
atteint bah il ya de la communication
qui est mise en place
je trouve très intéressant parce qu'il
ya donc un apiculteur référent qui va se
charger de la gestion des ruches ce qui
est très intéressant je trouve c'est que
semble qu'il ya des étudiants qui sont
intéressés qui vont gérer les ruches car
pour le moment c'est peut-être pas très
structuré mais visiblement ça va se
mettre en place et au mois de juin 2018
il y aura les apidays dans les happy
days c'est des journées qui sont
importantes puisque c'est des journées
sont organisées de façon à mettre en
place des ateliers ludiques pédagogiques
et d'aller à la rencontre des personnes
je trouve intéressant quand même le
l'endroit où était déposé les ruches
parce qu'en fait ça correspond aussi à
une attention politique je pense que le
pea en tant qu'aménageur un rôle
important à jouer en matière de
biodiversité faire attention
la trame verte la trame bleue et bat
aussi aux espèces qu'on a m parce que là
ils sont vraiment en plein aménagement
qu'on met si celui-ci possible donc des
arbres mellifères des plantes mellifères
de façon à favoriser la biodiversité
parce qu'en fait des abeilles a laissé
un problème qu'elles ont également c'est
que ce qu'il faut qu'elle trouve à
manger et que si on met que des plantes
qui n'apportera rien au niveau nectar ça
n'avance pas grand chose donc la nar
lisière c'est une zone qui est conçu
aussi et qui aura un intérêt écologique
et pour la biodiversité
on s'arrête maintenant sur une autre
inauguration celle du programme
qualifiant territoriale constructeur
professionnel en voirie et réseaux une
opportunité pour 15 demandeurs d'emploi
ils vont pouvoir se former dans le
secteur du bâtiment et des travaux
publics
rencontre avec le coordinateur de ce
projet timothée béraud
[Musique]
oh
aujourd'hui on est sur l'inauguration du
programme qualifiant territorialisée
donc ce dispositif financé par la le
conseil régional ile de france on a pu
bénéficier de cette subvention régionale
suite à un besoin exprimé par les
entreprises au cours d'une enquête qui a
été menée sur le territoire par
l'ensemble des partenaires du réseau de
l'emploi et l'insertion qui a détecté
des besoins dans le cadre de cette
démarche de gpec territoriale entre
autres sur les métiers des travaux
publics de la un partenariat est né avec
le pea paris saclay et à tout prix pour
mener une action de formation in situ
sur un marché dont eiffage des
attributaires
donc de là s'est engagé un large
partenariat autour de d'eiffage d'autres
entreprises adhérentes de la fédération
régionale des travaux publics mais
également du côté de notre organisme de
formation et de notre réseau de
partenaires prescripteurs de demandeurs
d'emploi local on a pu me constituer un
groupe de quinze stagiaires qui vont se
former sur une durée de huit cent quatre
heures centre pour le coup sur le
plateau technique et en salle des cent
cinq heures en entreprise au travers de
deux stages l'idée étant pour ces
demandeurs d'emploi d'accéder à un titre
professionnel de constructeur
professionnel en voirie réseaux et bien
évidemment d'accéder à l'emploi derrière
pour un cdd de longue durée ou le cdi
donc ça va se faire directement sur ce
terrain le stage en entreprise fera
seraient entreprises locales aux
alentours de palaiseau sur le territoire
de la communauté paris saclay ou du pays
dit mot
[Musique]
l'edf là c'est à lui de recherche mais
c'est aussi un lieu de vie il a
accueilli une exposition itinérante
l'observateur du design
c'était une grande première paris-saclay
tv vous présente la vingtaine de projets
présentés les objets du futur
[Musique]
on est très contents d'accueillir cette
exposition dans ce haut lieu un petit
peu emblématique laboratoire de saclay
que nous avons joint maintenant il ya un
peu plus d'un an et qui regroupe 1000
chercheurs c'est la première fois qu'on
accueille une expo itinérante
c'est la première fois qu'on accueille
une expo itinérante sur le design donc
c'est extrêmement important et on est
aussi très très heureux qu'elle soit
ouverte au public dans un lieu qu'il est
aussi donc ça permet pour les visiteurs
de faire d'une pierre deux coups de
découvrir un laboratoire une grande
entreprise française
df et puis découvrir la vingtaine de
projets qui sont exposés à l'intérieur
du bâtiment
on sanctionne des réalisations donc au
sens des fonctionnalités qui sont
démontrés par les produits les services
qui sont présentés mais on sanctionne
aussi des démarches qui ont utilisé les
techniques et les pratiques du design
pour mettre au point ce et ses solutions
donc on est bien sur deux dimensions la
dimension fonctionnalités des produits
et la dimension démarche d'innovation
qui a été mise en avant
[Musique]
l'exposition qui nous occupe elle
présente en fait des produits et
services compte et lauréat de l'édition
2016 2017 et donc fait l'objet de prix
remis en décembre 2007 une nouvelle
édition est partie l'édition 2018 qui
fera l'objet de remises de prix en
décembre de cette année là au centre
georges pompidou le 5 décembre
[Musique]
maintenant tous à vos agendas voilà tout
ce qu'il ne faudra pas rater dans les
jours à venir avec déjà cette exposition
qui se déroule jusqu'au 26 novembre et
qui nous invite à rêver à et
architecture rêver la ville quarante ans
de création urbaine
c'est à l'espace boris vian les ulis le
21 novembre ça que les plantes enough
2017 vous donne rendez-vous à
gif-sur-yvette à l'institut de sciences
des plantes paris saclay c'est la
quatrième édition
cette journée permet de favoriser les
échanges entre les équipes de recherche
et des partenaires
objectif faire émerger des projets dino
un rendez vous devenu incontournable
tedx saclay ce sera centrale supélec le
30 novembre
pour cette troisième édition les 13
intervenants s'intéresseront aux thèmes
suivants au service du vivant des débats
qui seront suivis en direct à lima au
pérou et enfin le 8 décembre sera une
journée scientifique on réfléchira à la
santé de demain au cea
le labex digi comme planche sur lies
santé ce sera à nano innov à palaiseau
voilà vous savez tout c'est la fin de
cette émission
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi vous
pouvez la voir où la revoir sur le pap
est ce point fr ou son tv 78 moi je vous
dis à très bientôt
[Musique]